ce soir on a
gagné
venflam
écoute plaisir ici en blanc s
brillamment qualifié pour les quarts de
finale de fédéral 3 une première dans
l'histoire du club avec TR essai inscrit
les Plaisirois ont étouffé leurs
adversaires de la première à la 80e
minute pour l'emporter 25 à0 on a su
marquer dans moment fort on a été on a
su
pragmatique on a su super bien défendre
surtout sur moment faible on a été là on
a été présent on a rien lâché
aujourd'hui tout nous a souri ben la
chance sourit aux audacieux c'est ce
qu'on dit toujours mais c'est vrai que
bah voilà le résultat est là c'est que
on a fait des super des super super
actions de jeu l'une des principales
satisfactions de la journée la défense
pour la 4e fois de la saison plaisir n'a
concédé aucun point on a vraiment mis le
cœur à l'ouvrage en terme d'agressivité
on était vraiment présent bien organisé
c'est quelque chose qu'on travaille
depuis quelques temps et euh
et je pense c'est ce qui a payé
aujourd'hui au prochain tour les
Plaisirois affronteront tour une équipe
que les ivinois avaient affronté en
fédéral 2 en 2015 on sait que c'est bien
organisé donc il y a même pas à penser
au titre aujourd'hui il faut prendre les
matchs comme ils viennent il faut jouer
il faut jouer il faut les jouer on verra
ce qui se passe c'est ce qu'on a fait
aujourd'hui le match contreetour sera
programmé le 11 juin prochain sur
terrain neutre en attendant plaisir peut
savourer le club fait partie des h
meilleures équipes du championnat sur
160 clubs
engagés